mise de la vie ne reprendra pas de la
même façon je n'adhère pas à cette
théorie du monde d'avant du monde
d'après je crois que le groupe d'avants
il était formidable et qu'on a envie de
le retrouver pensais que ça allait me
rendre plus tolérante et ça m'a rendu
plus intolérant alors par mois elle
s'était imposée justement délirer autour
d'un dessert que j'ai appelé la pêche
l'abattage
je voulais vraiment montrer que le monde
d'après il serait aussi dynamique et
nicole notamment
[Musique]
avec la fin de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire la trêve hivernale se termine
aujourd'hui en france après trois mois
de prolongation exceptionnelle face aux
menaces d'expulsion cet été
l'association droit au logement demande
une année blanche sur ses pratiques et
sur les coupures d'énergie
plusieurs organisations ont appelé à
manifester ce samedi vous le voyez à
paris d'où des tensions au mali au
lendemain de violentes manifestations
contre le pouvoir qui ont fait quatre
morts et 70 blessés à bamako troisième
protestation d'ampleur organisé en moins
de deux mois dans la capitale par le
mouvement du 5 juin
c'est une coalition de chefs religieux
d'hommes politiques et de représentants
de la société civile il conteste la
présidence d'ibrahim boubacar kéita qui
est au pouvoir depuis sept ans aux
manifs
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
lance une enquête sur les origines du
virus en chine deux experts de
l'organisation mondiale sont arrivés
aujourd'hui à pékin pour tenter
déterminer comment le virus a été
transmis à l'homme une initiative saluée
par les états unis alors que la
procédure de retrait de cette instance
internationale a été lancée en début de
semaine washington avait accusé l'om est
complaisance avec la chine
le virus qui jusqu'ici a fait plus de
cinq cent cinquante cinq mille morts
dans le monde
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france à la une
de l'actualité ce samedi les
manifestations à paris aujourd'hui à
l'appel des défenseurs du droit au
logement alors que l'état d'urgence
sanitaire a pris fin hier soir la trêve
hivernale ces deux fêtes terminées elles
aussi une trêve qui avait été prolongée
exceptionnellement de trois mois vous à
la crise sanitaire
à partir d'aujourd'hui donc les
expulsions sont autorisés et c'est
justement ce que craignent les
associations qui demandent une année
blanche au gouvernement
voyez les précisions sur place de notre
reporter basse m shelly ils étaient plus
d'une centaine à s'être donné rendez
vous au coeur de la capitale pour une
marche contre la reprise des expulsions
suite à la trêve hivernale qui avaient
été prolongés avec la crise du corona
virus mais surtout contre le mal
logement en france il demande au
gouvernement une année blanche des
expulsions une marche qui a commencé au
coeur de la capitale aux abords du musée
du louvre pour se terminer ici dans le
7e arrondissement en face du ministère
du logement le ministère du logement qui
a reçu une délégation de syndicats mais
surtout de membres de l'association
droit au logement je vous propose
d'écouter jamais blanchard un des
membres de cette association qui assiste
à la réunion voir on a été reçus et pise
organisations n'ont pas sans nous et
puis la cgt est un syndicat et puis
notamment un collectif de sans-papiers
ce qui a été dit ça a été les
obligations qui sont habituellement tous
les ans notamment l'acquisition des
bâtiments vides ils vont vite permettre
à ce que plus personne ne soit contraint
la rue et faire en sorte qu'ils aient
une vraie politique en faveur des
locataires une politique humaine
une politique qui soit pas dévoués comme
on l'a vu pendant confinement qui
permettent aux entreprises de pouvoir
voir des radiations loyer mais qu'on
pense aussi aux humains aux êtres
humains c'est à dire aux gens qui
subissent des conditions difficiles
conditions sociales très difficiles qui
peuvent par le logement faire en sorte
d'avoir enfin une dignité et surtout je
rappelle aussi parce qu'on n'en
passerait avec les personnes qui sont
sans abri je rappelle que les personnes
qui sont encore la ruée des personnes
qui ont été poussés priorité c'est juste
inacceptables une réunion qui s'est
terminée par des promesses selon
certains syndicats et certains membres
du dal le gouvernement a promis se
pencher sur cette situation sur la
question des expulsions mais surtout des
mal logés en attendant les membres de
l'association ont promis de poursuivre
le mouvement tant que le gouvernement ne
répondra pas favorablement à leurs
revendications et surtout ne répondra
pas favorablement à cette année blanche
qu'il demande concernant les expulsions
un succès pour jean castex qui est
parvenu à
le secteur de la santé après sept
semaines de concertation un accord sur
la revalorisation des salaires a été
trouvé avec les trois syndicats
majoritaires
l'état s'est engagé sur une enveloppe de
7 milliards cinq cent mille euros
cela représente une augmentation de
salaire de 183 euros nets mensuels qui
seront versés en deux fois et cela
concerne les personnels de santé ainsi
que le personnel des ehpad le secteur du
public ainsi que le secteur du privé
écoutez cet accord est un compromis
acceptable reconnaissant l'engagement
sans faille des agents hospitaliers et
des ehpad pendant la crise sanitaire et
pendant plusieurs années où ils étaient
les oubliés de la république
néanmoins ce protocole de revalorisation
n'est qu'une étape et ne saurait être le
solde de tout compte
un syndicaliste vous dira toujours qu'il
aurait voulu plus mais ça fait 2000 196
euros de plus par an quand on est
syndicaliste et qu'on s'est battu comme
notre fédération s'est battu on s'engage
là dessus parce que cet accord est un
gain salarial c'est la revalorisation
des grilles
la cgt et le syndicat sud dénonce je
cite une imposture avec quatre autres
organisations elles appellent à une
grande manifestation à paris le 14
juillet l'organisation demande une
augmentation de 300 euros
écoutez mireille estivale à de la cgt ça
fait 20 ans que les organisations
syndicales se battent justement pour des
augmentations de salaires aujourd'hui
une infirmière a une moyenne en tout cas
inférieur de 800 euros par rapport aux
autres pays européens
pour l'instant l'accord qui est proposé
n'est pas forcément à la hauteur en tout
cas des attentes
donc il est évident que les
professionnels continueront à se
mobiliser pour justement notamment
mettre la question des effectifs en
personnel qui n'est pas présente dans ce
protocole ou très près très peu près
vente puisque il faudrait 200 mille
emplois pour pouvoir leur répondre à aux
problèmes d'effectifs dans les
établissements c'est après une
consultation que nous donnerons notre
réponse définitive puisque nous n'avons
pas encore répondu en tout cas
à cette question donc de dire que pour
l'instant la cgt n'a et contre et ne
signera pas nous attendons nous la
consultation parce qu'il nous semble
normal que le personnel qui étaient
mobilisés depuis plus d'un an qu'il est
qu'il est important qu'on ne le consulte
avant de réserver une réponse définitive
le cap des trente mille morts liées au
virus a été franchie hier en france et
il y à 77 foyers de contamination sur le
territoire notamment en mayenne où on
gironde où certains experts redoutent
une résurgence de l'épidémie
si la femme il est lu table pour lézan
évitable pour les autres la possibilité
d'une deuxième vague de l'épidémie de
coronavirus ne fait pas consensus
un seul point d'accord parmi les
chercheurs et scientifiques
la circulation du virus ralenti
l'épidémie prospère désormais de manière
lente est endémique
c'est à dire que le virus est chez nous
et il fait des petits progrès qui sont
inéluctables avec le rétablissement de
la plupart des activités humaines
une reprise activité qui pourrait
expliquer l'apparition de clusters ici
ou là en allemagne en corée du sud ou
encore en chine mais qui reste
circonscrit à des petites zones
l'épidémie redémarre aussi dans des pays
qui étaient jusqu'à présent peu touchée
c'est le cas en inde avec près de 700
mille cas recensés pour plus d'1 3
milliard d'habitants landes est
désormais le troisième pays le plus
touché au monde en termes de
contamination d'autres pays comme
l'australie madagascar ou encore à
l'afrique du sud font face à une
résurgence de l'épidémie une reprise
dans ces pays de l'hémisphère sud
actuellement en période hivernale qui
pourrait suggérer une saisonnalité du
virus à l'instar de la grippe
et si c'est saisonnalité se confirmait
on pourrait craindre un redémarre âge de
l'épidémie dans l'hémisphère nord
lorsque les températures commenceront à
baisser
autre argument les scientifiques qui
croient à une seconde vague inévitable
la capacité du virus a su réactiver et à
se déclarer chez une personne déjà guéri
un virologue du centre national espagnol
de biotechnologie a ainsi estimé qu'au
moins 14 % des patients dont le test de
dépistage de kobe 19 s'étaient révélés
négatifs
était finalement revenu positif face à
ces prévisions pessimistes d'autres
scientifiques font preuve d'une plus
grande prudence voire même de
scepticisme actuellement on ne voit une
deuxième vague dans aucun pays du monde
seulement des cas sporadiques et des
réimportations issue de la phase
pandémique actuelle de nombreuses
données inconnues demeurent concernant
ce virus l'environnement existant au
moment où il s'est propagé n'est plus le
même aujourd'hui
pour ces spécialistes il n'y aurait donc
pas de deuxième vague mais tout
simplement une progression de l'épidémie
dont les zones encore peu touchées et où
on observe avant tout des cas importés
comme en corée du sud
certains vont même plus loin en
signalant que d'autres virus pourrait
nous immuniser contre le coc vides sont
même avoir été infectés par celui ci
c'est le principe de l'immunité croisé
l'immunité croisé protège votre
organisme contre un virus quand il a été
exposé à un autre virus dans le passé
par exemple si vous avez été infecté par
un coronavirus bénin comme un simple
rhume l'an passé vous pourriez avoir
produit des cellules ou des anticorps
qui vous protège contre le coronavirus
actuel en attendant que les
scientifiques se mettent d'accord le
message du nouveau gouvernement castex
et ton ne peut plus clair il faut se
tenir prêt en cas de deuxième vague la
ministre délégué à l'industrie agnès
pannier rue nash et à d'ailleurs indiqué
que les entreprises françaises seraient
incités à acheter des stocks de masques
pour l'ensemble de leurs salariés et ce
pour couvrir une période de dix semaines
au lendemain de cette annonce le titre
du groupe chargeurs qui est avec sa
branche lainière santé est l'un des
principaux producteurs de masques
tricolore a vu son titre en bourse gagné
3,7 points
la prudence affichée par le gouvernement
ne devrait donc pas faire que des
mécontents et une résurgence est elle
possible à la rentrée et voyez ce qu'on
pense jean-pierre wilhem il est co
fondateur de médecins sans frontières
le coeur du problème est là lequoy loeb
parce que si on se prend une à nouveau
et bien il va y avoir des drames c'est à
dire qu'évidemment l'économie va
s'écrouler et cetera chômage bon et il y
aura tous des sentiments négatifs qui
vont arriver là or le
la dépression etc qui ne sont pas bons
d'abord pour votre propre santé c'est
évident le stress n'a jamais été bon
pour le pour la santé et alors les gens
maintenant soparfin 1 on a vécu une
période on a relevé tout tout ce qui
était négative tout ce qui était un
parent créé et maintenant je pense qu'on
est à même de gérer
il est évident que tous les grands
systèmes médicaux officiel ou a été
défaillant ou le corps on le sait
maintenant donc on sait maintenant les
barrières les masques et cetera la
distance qu'il faut avoir on connaît
tout ça et je pense que on va en tirer
un profit et qu'il n'y aura pas le même
drame que lors de la première vague le
gouvernement sommé de mettre en place
des actions pour lutter contre la
pollution de l'air il a été sommé par le
conseil d'état sans mesures effectifs
dans les six prochains mois pour réduire
cette pollution atmosphérique
l'état devra payer une amende de 10
millions d'euros par semestre
le 12 juillet 2010 est le conseil d'état
avait déjà demandé à l'exécutif de
mettre en oeuvre des plans de réduction
des niveaux de particules et d'azoté
voyez la réaction d'olivier blond il est
président de l'association respire à la
première chose à faire c'est lancer un
grand plan d'action contre le diesel
parce que la décision du conseil d'état
elle porte sur des dépassements
principalement de dioxyde d azote dans
les centres villes
or ce dioxyde d azote il est quasiment
totalement émis en ville par les moteurs
diesel donc il faut il faut prendre des
décisions
on peut inscrire dans l'avenir bon la
perspective d'une interdiction totale
mais surtout ce qu'il faut faire c'est
aider les gens à changer de véhicule
alors les particuliers avec des
subventions avec des dés
dz les professionnels les chauffeurs de
taxi les vtc les artisans en les aidant
à chaque fois en lançant un grand
programme national de construction d'un
réseau de recharge
parce que c'est évidemment le le bas
le point difficile aujourd'hui et puis
en luttant après globalement contrôler
la pollution automobile avec les
transports actifs genre le le vélo la
marche en encourageant télétravail en
faisant plein de choses il ya des
dizaines et des dizaines de d'action
impossible nous respirons n'a proposé au
gouvernement
20 actions à apprendre dans les mois qui
viennent les solutions existent il faut
juste le courage politique de les mettre
en oeuvre
le bras de fer entre paris et washington
sur la taxe gafa en représailles à cette
taxe imposée par paris au géant du web
américain
les etats-unis ont annoncé des mesures
de rétorsion il s'agit de nouvelles
taxes qui viserait des importations
françaises
cela représente un milliard trois cent
mille dollars et concernerait des
produits cosmétiques surtout ainsi que
des sacs à main bercy campe sur sa
position selon l'entourage de bruno le
maire un accord sur la taxation du
numérique et je cite la seule issue fin
de citation voyez ce qu'on dit à ce
moment là elle est experte en économie
on a des plateformes et maître de
conférences à sciences po
en réalité ce qui est en train de jouer
c'est d'abord enfin elle se situe
d'abord et essentiellement sur un plan
symbolique puisque ce qu'on voit en fait
apparaître depuis quelques temps dans
l'économie mondiale est dans la posture
américaine c'est plutôt une position
d'un positionnement extrêmement
protectionniste est très très
protecteurs de leurs industries
stratégiques et donc notamment les
nouvelles technologies en particulier
les gars femmes
donc en ce sens n'est pas du tout les
lubies qu'on pourrait croire d'un train
de complètement fou mais c'est une vraie
stratégie commerciale aujourd'hui qui
est protectionniste d'une part des
marchés intérieurs et des des grandes et
des grands secteurs stratégiques
américains d'une part et puis par
rapport au marché mondial
une attitude qui est pour le coup
extrêmement hégémonique expansionniste
donc en ce sens la décision des états
unis d'abord de se retirer aide
des accords de l' ocde il y à un mois de
ça et ensuite aujourd'hui de de menacer
en fait de rétorsion n'est absolument
pas du tout étonnant de ce produit là au
mali quatre morts et une vingtaine de
blessés hier lors d'une nouvelle
manifestation anti gouvernementale c'est
la troisième en deux mois une assemblée
nationale qui a été incendié des locaux
de médias publics occupés des ponts
bloquer ou des monuments ou vandalisés à
bamako donc une foule réclame la
démission du président ibrahim boubacar
keïta qui est en place depuis 2013
le président malien qui a annoncé dans
la nuit de son côté un message de
fermeté
il a annoncé l'ouverture d'une enquête
les contestataires appellent à la
désobéissance civile comme prévu par la
constitution
deux chefs de l'opposition ont été
interpellés aujourd'hui
le président est resté saoul alors
propositions aujourd'hui la seule chose
qui nous reste c'est de lui proposer la
constitution c'était la constitution
prévoit c'est à dire l'article 121 qui
prônent la désobéissance civile
nous avons obligé d'écouter voie dès que
je passe là texan maintien nous donne
quand même et c'est les coûts des
pouvoirs demandés soit départ et nous
allons les laisser dans cette doxa
civile
si c'est pour être là aujourd'hui je
mets a peut être des mères pour le
dépensons le départ j'ai pas envoyer ses
potentiels humains ne sont plus des
palais des arts asselah et voyez
l'analyse de m6 et il est porte-parole
du conseil supérieur de la diaspora
malienne
aujourd'hui vous avez là écrasante
majorité de la population qui vous
prochain certains la cité un laxisme il
ya eu toute cette crise est due après
les élections législatives
il a été plus de sécurité entre
guillemets nommé et non élu
ce qui est demandé clairement c'est par
les manifestants
c'est la démission du président ibrahim
boubacar kéïta la dissolution de
l'assemblée nationale
remanié le coq la cour constitutionnelle
parce que c'est là qu'au conditionnel
cas programme qui a proclamé ce genre de
résultat qui aujourd'hui amène la rue à
tandil près il a été pendu pétanque la
république et aujourd'hui on s'en va on
va tout droit vers une insurrection une
insurrection populaire
j'ai rarement vu une pub le malien
profil déterminé des jusqu'au boutistes
à la une de ce journal également
l'organisation mondiale de la santé qui
lance une enquête sur les origines du
virus en chine deux experts de l'om est
sont arrivés aujourd'hui à pékin pour
déterminer comment le virus aurait été
transmis à l'homme
une initiative qui a été saluée par les
états unis alors que la procédure de
retrait de cette instance internationale
a été lancée en début de semaine par
washington
souvenez-vous washington qui avait
accusé le ms de complaisance avec la
chine
retour en images sur ces tensions
[Musique]
depuis le début de l'épidémie en chine
11 millions de personnes ont été testées
5000 placés en quarantaine
pékin affirme que plus de huit nouveaux
cas sur 10 proviendrait de l'étranger le
point avec walid belani c'est un retour
à la normale près de 11 millions de
lycéens chinois ont bien pris le chemin
de l'un des sept mille centres d'examen
met en place dans tout le pays
contrairement à la france les étudiants
de dernière année du secondaire passe le
concours national d'entrée à
l'université dont des classes la crise
sanitaire presque un lointain souvenir
d'abord j'ai trouvé que c'était un peu
difficile de respirer mais après j'étais
complètement concentré sur l'examen je
ne faisais pas attention aux masques
passer l'examen d'entrée à l'université
dans cette situation particulière de
l'épidémie est une expérience éprouvante
pour lui qui le rendra plus auto
discipline et après avoir révisé est
étudié pour l'examen à la maison pendant
si longtemps un million de surveillants
ont été réquisitionnés pour déceler la
moindre tricherie fièvre ou encore two
suspecte prudence contrôle maîtres mots
d'un gouvernement qui ne laisse plus
rien passer
pour preuve 11 millions de personnes ont
été testées dans la capitale depuis un
mois 5000 ont été placés en quarantaine
partiellement la découverte début juin
d'un foyer de contamination dans un
marché alimentaire de gros du sud de
pékin avec 335 personnes infectées
semble avoir été maîtrisé les autorités
chinoises ont annoncé jeudi n'avoir
recensé aucun nouveau cas de kovy 19
pour le troisième jour d'affilée
aujourd'hui la chine envoie un message
fort au reste du monde et
particulièrement aux états unis
rien n'est plus précieux que les vies
humaines
rien n'est plus urgent que de sauver des
vies nous avons une profonde sympathie
pour le peuple américain pour ses
expériences malheureuses
l'épidémie et nous avons fourni aux
etats unis une énorme quantité de
matériel médical dont il avait grand
besoin
il devrait travailler avec la chine pour
promouvoir la réponse mondiale au coït
19 afin de sauver plus de vies et être à
la hauteur de notre responsabilité
internationale en tant que grand pays ce
jeudi plus de 30 diplomates et experts
de haut niveau du monde entier ont
participé à un débat par visioconférence
un forum sino-américain
après avoir été le tout premier foyer de
l'épidémie
pékin souhaite aujourd'hui rassurés et
prévenir le gouvernement a annoncé
vouloir interdire la consommation et le
commerce d'animaux sauvages ou encore a
déjà stoppé l'importation de produits
aquatiques
l'afrique est là à dépasser le cap des
500 milles contamination déclaré près de
la moitié des cas concernent uniquement
l'afrique du sud avec un tiers dans la
province du gauteng
c'est une province dans le nord du pays
où le premier ministre a même été testés
positifs sur place et les hôpitaux sont
confrontés vous allez le voir à une
pénurie d'oxygène rania berrada dans cet
hôpital de pretoria l'oxygène commence à
manquer et certains patients faute de
lits sont soignés sous des tentes
chauffées dans le parking
récemment la province du gauteng où se
situe la capitale administrative
d'afrique du sud est devenu le nouvel
épicentre de l'épidémie dans le pays
en visite vendredi dans cet hôpital
le ministre de la santé a prévenu que le
pire était à venir
nous avons indiqué au cours des derniers
jours comme nous l'avons vu au cours des
derniers mois que l'épidémie est en
train de se propager
c'est le début de ce que nous pouvons
décrire comme une tempête à laquelle
nous devons nous préparer
le ministre de la santé a indiqué que
les autorités travailler avec des
industriels afin de remédier à la
pénurie d'oxygène il a également promis
davantage de moyens
even tout seul
nous avons décidé de doter tous les
hôpitaux de 250 lits répartis sur
plusieurs établissements
céline nous permettront de faire face
aux admissions quotidiennes croissantes
que nous constatons dans tous les
hôpitaux la région du gauteng compte un
tiers des sud-africains contaminée par
le kobe 19 en prévision de la tempête
annoncé le ministère de la santé fait
creuser des tombes dans un cimetière de
pretoria cette semaine le pays a
enregistré le nouveau triste record de
13 mille cas confirmés en 24 heures et
on termine par cette nouvelle polémique
concernant la société d'actifs
américaine blackrock lundi dernier une
enquête a été ouverte par la médiatrice
de l'union européenne enquête ouverte
après une plainte déposée par une ong et
des eurodéputés
il soupçonne des conflits d'intérêts qui
allie kotick off on a beaucoup entendu
parler de blackrock
surtout ces derniers mois la société de
gestion d'actifs créée en 1988 par larry
fink est devenu numéro un mondial du
secteur au fil des décennies
l'entreprise est longtemps restée
discrète bien connu du monde de la
finance certes mais pas du grand public
ce n'est qu'après la crise financière de
2008 que les médias se sont mises à la
mettre en lumière en raison de sa
puissance de la taille de la portée de
ses actifs ainsi que de ses activités
financières
elle gère aujourd'hui environ 6500
milliards de dollars soit 5 1750
milliards d'euros confiés par ses
clients
6500 milliards de dollars c'est le pib
de la france et de l'allemagne réunies
blackrock c'est quasiment un état
l'entreprise est tellement puissante à
des participations dans un si grand
nombre d'entreprises dans le monde que
si supposons un venait à faire faillite
cela entraînerait de véritable risque
systémique pour l'économie mondiale tout
entière
par ailleurs et entre autres c'est un
des plus grands investisseurs dans la
fabrication d'armes
n'en déplaise aux pacifistes et l'un des
trois principaux investisseurs dans les
huit plus importantes sociétés
pétrolières au monde
n'en déplaise aux écolos le travail de
blackrock est de collecter de l'argent
auprès de fonds de pension banques ou
assureurs pour l'investir sur les
marchés financiers
pdg larry fink côtoie régulièrement des
chefs d'état du monde entier qu'ils
écoutent ses conseils économiques d'une
oreille attentive comme le président
mexicain andres manuel lopez obrador
donc etats unis inde allemagne les
conseils de l'arrêt films sont partout
au plus haut sommet de l'état et il peut
dire qu'il sait recruter un article du
monde explique jusqu'en février 2020 la
filiale allemande de blackrock était
présidée par friedrich merckx en lice
pour succéder à angela merkel à la tête
du cd ou en 2017 le think tank de
blackrock a recruté l'ancien chancelier
de l'échiquier george osborne approche
de boris johnson et en octobre 2017
quelques mois après l'élection d'
emmanuel macron une vingtaine de grands
investisseurs mondiaux triés sur le
volet par blackrock comme le rappelle le
monde est invité par l'elysée et
matignon pour découvrir la politique
économique du nouveau quinquennat en
plein projet de réforme des retraites et
le président de blackrock jean françois
cirelli qui reçoit la légion d'honneur
pas étonnant qu'en france blackrock ne
soit pas vue d'un très bon oeil par ceux
qui depuis de nombreux mois
descendre dans la rue pour protester
contre cette réforme mais pour le
président de blackrock france pensait
que l'entreprise aurait un rôle à jouer
d intérêt à tirer de la réforme
relèverait du fantasme absolu
fin de citation pourtant entre 2002 et
2004 jean-françois cirelli a quand même
travaillé avec jean pierre raffarin
pendant la mise en place de la réforme
fillon sur les retraites et nous
blackrock qui avons que vous me l'avez
dit une expérience nous voulons mettre
d'autres expériences au service de cette
nouvelle épargne retraite
je croyais que c'était un fantasme
absolu bref voilà une entreprise qui
pèse très lourd et dans de très nombreux
secteurs banques industries pétrolières
industries d'armement alors blackrock
nommé conseiller environnemental pour
les banques par lieu un peu comme si on
demandait aux époux balkany et d'écrire
un rapport sur comment lutter contre la
fraude fiscale
bienvenue comment se fait-il que ce
géant tentaculaire et ait été choisi en
avril dernier parmi huit concurrents
pour conseiller l'union européenne sur
la façon d'intégrer au mieux les
facteurs environnementaux et sociaux
dans la supervision bancaire
nous ne comprenons pas pourquoi la
commission européenne n'a pas pensé
qu'il y aurait un conflit d'intérêts
énorme avec ce choix
pas impossible en effet mais bon la
commission européenne la sueur
cette offre était en pleine et stricte
conformité avec les règles applicables
de lieux en matière de marchés publics y
compris celles concernant l'éligibilité
des soumissionnaires et la prévention de
tout conflit d'intérêts potentiel et
blackrock de calmer le jeu sa branche
conseil qui assurent la prestation
n'aurait rien à voir avec sa branche
d'investissement et blackrock se dit
honorée d'éclairer le plan d'action de
la commission européenne sur la finance
durable
bon bah tout va bien alors et c'est la
fin de ce journal merci de votre
fidélité sur notre antenne
on se retrouve dans 30 minutes rester
avec
[Musique]
recevons pauline d'orgeval présidente et
cofondatrice de kohat petit santé le
pratiquent même de notre association
c'est de réduire les inégalités d'accès
à la santé et d'accès aux soins
on se rencontre que les personnes en
situation de handicap notamment ont été
largement oubliée et donc je suis fini
par renoncer aux soins vous avez proposé
deux posters en falck ça que ça veut
dire
facile à lire facile à comprendre on a
fait des posters sur ce qu'était le
confinement à l'aide d'illustrations